a route in the u.s stock market this
spring pushed down the combined net
worth of the nation's richest self-made
women to 111 billion dollars a six
percent drop from last year and lowered
the admission cut off to 215 million
dollars
down from 225 million dollars a year ago
38 of the 100 on this list are worth
less than 2021 but 51 women are
wealthier including seven newcomers and
seven who returned to the ranks after
having previously fallen off among the
notable new faces movie star sandra
bullock and reoccurring shark tank judge
emma green
but these are the top five wealthiest
self-made women of 2022
in a tie for number four we have marion
illege it was another record year for
little caesars the pizza chain ilitch
co-founded with her husband mike in
1959.
system-wide sales reached 4.8 billion
dollars in 2021 up from 4.5 billion
illich's detroit red wings missed the
nhl playoffs for the sixth straight
season after having qualified for 25
years in a row
she and her son chris who run illitch
holdings are partnering with billionaire
developer steven ross as lead donors of
a 250 million dollar university of
michigan research and education center
in detroit
also in fourth is john l hunt who made
her fortune in the trucking industry
hunt rang in her 90th birthday this year
at an arkansas razorbacks basketball
game where the state's richest woman was
treated to cake and cheers during
halftime
the matriarch of jb hunt transport
services which she co-founded in 1961
with her late husband has plenty to
celebrate strong demand for freight
transport pushed revenue up 26 last year
to a record 12.2 billion dollars she is
the largest shareholder with a 17
stake
judy love sits at number three thanks to
continued expansion of love's travel
stops and country stores which judy and
her husband tom founded in 1964.
the 25.5 billion company now run by two
of their sons opened 38 new locations in
2021 and 18 in the first five months of
2022
judy is a director of the love family
fund the family's charitable foundation
the second richest self-made woman is
judy faulkner her medical records
company epic systems booked 3.8 billion
dollars in 2021 revenue up 13 from 2020.
the wisconsin-based business rolled out
a covid19 vaccine passport tool now
available to its 106 million patients
who use its mychart software
faulkner owns 47 percent of the business
she founded in her basement in 1979 and
coming in at number one is diane
hendricks who made her 12.2 billion
fortune through her building supplies
company abc supply
hendrix has benefited from a
pandemic-inspired residential housing
boom
her fortune has grown by more than one
billion dollars this past year thanks to
record sales at abc supply the wholesale
building supplies distributor she
co-founded with her husband
its sales hit nearly 15 billion dollars
up from 12.1 billion dollars in 2020.
you